one thing about occupy la is that it is
uh it is not so has not become
self-conscious as has in New York or in
Boston we solve a lot of people who are
who are sorted is still driving around
know like like Los Angeles became the
first city to officially endorse the
Occupy movement when it's City Council
unanimously passed the resolution
recognizing occupy la is right to camp
out on the lawns in front of city hall
council members had glowing words for
occupy la these are things were Leo
protest and I were speaking out how they
move the debate over and many of the
protesters have equally glowing words
for their city government they saw it as
a vibrant expression of our First
Amendment rights and we wanted that
because we've had such a good
relationship with the LAPD I feel really
happy about that because it's showing
the support from the government to what
we're doing I think it's great I think
that what's happening is we're actually
working with the local government so is
the Occupy movement unashamedly
pro-government or is there room for
libertarian sentiment within it the
answer is well it's complicated the last
four elections I actually voted
libertarian I will not vote democratic
or republican I don't trust my
government anymore this movement is not
anti politics nor is it anti politicians
it's about people participating
their rights as citizens of this country
I think that the government's going to
try to certain politicians are going to
try to side with us so they can use it
to their advantage a political advantage
but we the people are not going to allow
that I think that the Federal Reserve is
more like of a pet issue for
libertarians who have the privilege to
you know read and talk about that sort
of thing I'm here more for economic
justice the occupied movement is nothing
if not diverse and tolerant of a wide
range of political opinion i think that
the zionist jews who are running these
big banks in our Federal Reserve which
is not run by the federal government
they need to be run out of this country
okay that's not the best example
everyone's included everyone's got a
voice everyone's important it's not the
individual it's the collective there has
to be a form a form of government or
organizing ourselves in a way where we
know that I could eat and I have food
but not at the cost of other other like
four or five people having food I think
we can have more of a libertarian
government system I think less
government is the answer the Occupy
movement with its focus on big banks and
corporate bailouts seems to share at
least some concerns with the Tea Party
so is there any chance of an alliance
again it's complicated the tea party
seems to be focused on things that like
for instance you heard a lot of them say
you know keep the government
my Medicare they're not tuned in they've
been co-opted the Tea Party movement is
talking about a whole different thing
they don't like government at all we're
the only ones here that are standing up
to corporations are those in some ways
two sides of the same point no they're
not because if there would have been
regulations in place for the invisible
markets that came up in 2008 you know
with the collateralized loans and all of
that you like there was there were no
regulations about this at all you know a
bit about the Tea Party and what they're
doing and I think these movements are
related they're both extreme and that
they are basically saying that we need
to do away with the system the system
doesn't work so far despite attempts by
unions or politicians to latch on to the
movement it stayed fiercely independent
and for better or worse participants
don't want that to change anytime soon
for occupy Los Angeles I am a little bit
concerned about unions and their
organization I realize that they've
joined this movement to a certain extent
I just hope that we do not allow them to
use it for their game we have to
continue to be critical because there is
that risk is always that risk of
somebody i was taking of co-opting and
you know i'm changing it the government
is
is mommy and daddy and you take a stand
and see whether you're with mommy or
daddy or your independent citizen so I
don't mean to get too literal with it
but mommy and dad mommy will be the
Democrats that either a bubble I'm sure
you understand what I'm saying will like
read through the words I'm just using
symbols as the way of conveying a lot of
truth